you got everything tonight no you get it
ready we'll do it's the Lord's Day comes
up is we're [__] around you want to
[__] around going out with your buddies
a much pineapple Express there's the
real deal here [__] look at
leak on back please man get when they
start coming he's an all-star while you
sitting there [__] [__] around
through the fire department even come
and they sent DMT work that thing work
that Compton hey you're going a [__]
animal and he oh [__] talking about a
cardio cardio [__]
BAM there you go there your hat [__]
he's fine he's gonna be fine that Sunday
was talking a week off with a [__]
bang we're gonna wait till tomorrow
[__] tomorrow's a special day we got
[__] to do people to see and what has
just popped up in front of our eyes
another [__] surprise on a Sunday
night Lee says he's been in training he
has the same training open up with 600 a
look at this [__] this is like I said
McDonald's so stars
this would be their [__] when you
call it Big Mac attack
okay 600 milligrams of [__] dead
stars the purple ones this is the [__]
they give you if we have to [__] vet
to start him Vietnam vets and [__] yeah
BAM
but look what off the guy oh [__] we're
gonna mix and match tonight what's this
little that's so [__] hey oh [__]
yeah too much don't wanna do six and oh
[__] it might be an ugly night I'm
saying what Steve Simone but [__] it
we're back I missed you I missed you
[__] along I love it on my heart
you back on the [__] this thing is
like a finger in a [__] chick with a
missing the listen like that universe is
out you over here finger bang get to
that [__] noodle in there
what do you think though yeah I get the
renewal [__]
BAM the body of Christ compels you
[__]
stop drinking water Li the same [__]
Saudi Arabia [__] leaves over
there drinking water to take the taste
away try to swallow it anyway we're here
we're queer it's a beautiful night
always remember it's the Lord's Day
[__] maybe you're watching
lawrence welk or you hanging out with
uncle Joey
some of you guys don't even know the
[__] Lawrence walk is it doesn't matter
well we're ready for another bong hit
it's that [__] time you like Joey
what did you bring with you today
we broke the black canister debt too bad
there's only one more hit left and I
gave Lee the other you know I try to
take care of Lee I'm going to say
[__] Joey's ass gotta mooch I want to
hit this Tony's Delhi tomorrow I've been
hearing things I'm Magnolia Boulevard
right there well then where are
Lancashire hits whatever I wanna hit
this phony stuff
terrible terrible here's to you
[__] cuz I love you that's why I
do this like would Jesus he died for
your sins I'm [__] smoking reefer for
your sins you understand me nobody loses
what's up dawg
well that's not good
look at that that's what I'm talking
about right there [__] is nothing
better than a Sunday a little high and
dry Steve Simone Lisa I yet
and your uncle Joey
just just chilling this is it this one
it's all about no drama
I don't need no [__] big celebrities
hear nothing but heart this [__] room
hunting balls [__] and good music
good a [__] American music concept is
what
little thin mint but now let's give Li
the Skywalker
he's the Skywalker ten minutes they got
too many calories
oh [__]
the body of Christ compels you you've
been [__] around all weekend but
Papa's back [__] [__] around playing
tennis and [__] hanging out with your
buddies with wee little alligators on
this shirt but it's over now it's over
uncle Joey's back and back with a heart
attack BAM there we go hit it
get that captain Lee hit that little
[__] me we'll take that there you go
that's the one that's the one you saw
that's the one that's the one and only
right there look at the lungs are coming
up you think he gives a [__] he's
spitting the [__] damn finish that
that's a good one for you that's that
Skywalker I told you guys last week that
Scott Walker
I got his debt get my napkin Steve
similar to me drooling that's my boy
right there look at him in training you
don't give a [__] most people I smoked
so much weed I'd still drool 30 years
that means really gonna best okay take
that old smoke on it that's bad for your
lungs it's like black gas like Gracie
says don't worry about where it went we
got plenty more that canceled
[__] that [__] will hit that man hit
like enough for y'all hit of a comeback
I did it
love you think there's nothing better
this watch it
we're trying to give these people show
that at home on a Sunday they're on a
wheel cuz we're not we're not a wee
little tip that Neil [__] ladies
look suck that meal slowly and then pop
that helmet BAM
there you go we say act like a [__]
look at you look at when the [__] you
dealt with a man like this man never
[__]
you're down oh when you're down
and sitting that's that you know and we
forgot oh [__] well I haven't seen you
for [__] days on my side against
thousand on a Sunday night thousand
milligrams we're mixing up tonight you
know why we do this people cuz we have
time to [__] around you want you to know
we're coming out feet from the [__]
trenches here ain't no sense of [__]
you people they I know these guys get
the [__] out of it there's no pictures
of me eating okay nothing
and straight-up call the soul no save
hat for [__] Tuesday yeah the whole
[__] thing
the whole thing luck saving for Tuesday
or Wednesday when you're needed
yeah where's the valium keep the whole
[__] who I have some xanax is to bring
it down just in case you get suicidal
just in case you need suicidal thoughts
of [__] what the [__] point smoking I
get suicidal thoughts
I'm just saying I don't know what the
[__] I'm saying I got a nun you to me 22
fine it's all [__] like this
you gotta see Lee's face it's like
somebody fought in his mouth like what
says that baby this goes down at the
cave
the Voodoo Lounge mrs. M there's no
money there's no fun
ain't nobody yelping the [__] one
let's Yelp this and see what they know
know that [__] here we ain't Google and
effects of THC we don't give a [__]
we take we take huh
we take our chances here you know I'm
saying if you're not gonna take a chance
- I [__] live do you ever think about
that where I live
we're gonna keep looking at Yelp and
keep googling how the [__] you gonna
enjoy your life then you gotta say some
guys turned me on to his restaurant [__]
no I discovered this way Christopher
[__] Columbus I'm up and down and in
between yeah it's all [__] it's time for
buckets
I got my whiskey
are you doing up they goes ladies and
gentlemen
that's a savage in training right there
wiggle uncle Joey oh [__] oh [__]
your [__] better get it
together we're gonna [__] if you thought
we just blasted off with blasts long
deeply [__] but about 20 minutes we'll
be talking Brazilian I see what we got
this one this one is empty done just
like that there's something that you
keep it there we'll save that for the
earthquake you insane what we got here
we got a little segment we're gonna pack
a double pack police I am saying that
even rhyme it's your three Frank you're
sitting in it it's your true friend
oh [__] this is the one people there's
the one he's been played before
this is it
knock his lung out of the line that you
like that won't be battle
you pulled this one on the top okay yeah
sure
that suck again real quick they go take
that car bomb here you go Lee this is
the one right here
this is the one that killed Zeus
don't get no better yet I sure don't
belong to me is the best finish that hit
don't be breathing that smoke coming
next
oh I'm sorry but it's true
what do you want to know what yeah you
gotta finish them wait money though it's
not good people would kill for that
right thing you finished yet I'm not I'm
gonna background no I got some
tremendous way that I hate them
let's go come on what are you gonna
finger finger on the gate sorry no way
every time that's my caucus I'm smoking
charcoal
legal
we're back we're back [__] yeah I
don't know what you expect out of life
you do your job you work five days a
week six days a week I work seven days a
week um in there I'm getting up doing
this doing that writing this and an
email for that this guy hasn't paid you
know ain't never [__] an ex and then
you gotta write then you gotta be a dad
and then you gotta be a [__] human
being then you'll be a comedian
then gonna do a podcast what the [__] my
arms are heavy [__]
where's that [__] refresh my nose is
getting better for use that [__] ass
I'm breathing you know everything's
beautiful I spit out a sketchy looking
at a piece of bacon it was three inches
[__] long Steve Simone they came from
my [__] I fell about over here I do
the same line wash and all sudden I
[__] blew my nose they just flew out
it was tremendous I looked at it for
about 25 minutes that's all you could do
in your brains then I felt like a Canada
all the scab I ate delicious the fungi
though yes I did
I chewed that [__] like a
[__] like that will those mints like
you're like assert that [__] thing was
on an assert though it was like assert
the tic-tock put together had a little
heart as a result I bit into that
[__] was as hard as a clam yes I
did
like [__] blood snot and scab put
together you never ate a scab off your
knee what the [__] is wrong with America
a good little scab off you need salty it
gets hard it's like a it's like a
[__] like a pigtail play when the
Puerto Ricans cooking the tail gets all
crunchy tell me none of you
[__] never ate a scab off
indeed what type of my [__] [__]
what about the nose it had moisture to
it it's nice they have like a clam
effect to your mouth using the type of
people I'm dealing with I'm gonna change
this podcast from the church what's
happening now to the bomb that's it
that's it that's it no I love it I can't
you know I worked hard this week my wife
I gave my wife what I had last week so I
had the baby tremendous one of the best
[__] four hours of my [__] life
yesterday for my mouth I took her out of
the house like at 9:15 the park Boston
Market Basket Robins back to a different
part I ran a like a [__] racehorse
she fell I didn't let it cry don't cry
don't ever let him answer you crying
[__] my wife said what happened to a
chick she's got a bruise on it nothing
that's how we run that [__] house and
[__] vote for Hillary are you [__]
nuts are you [__] nuts
oh [__]
I don't know if you guys know [__] up
right now but hey it's my [__] front
it's my tree Frank I'm Sydney
are you ready for another fondly pleased
looking at me going you know why Joey
it's time for another fun
we're gonna put some [__] music to
fit that savoir faire
savoir faire is everywhere millena
cartoon we're gonna [__] listen to
some real double music ouchies he picks
like music dint like I wouldn't want to
listen to by myself at night what type
of [__] here hell is for children what
type of people were you get higher you
go home you put your phones on you
listen to [__] music that's what most
people do you understand me you sit
there and you think about your [__]
life away you went wrong and you let the
brilliance take your way like this deck
right here
and with that once you put Zeppelin on
you gotta [__] burn something a body a
[__] dog's tail you guys do something
understand oh [__]
what's the matter weak what you have
ideas on it was an April morning when
they told us we should know you [__]
crate legally look at what Matthew
Simone the a little [__] military he
didn't go to [__] doctor whatever this
will eat Frankie Lymon
that's right man Steve Simone Oklahoma
Cherokee Casino Saturday night 8 o'clock
be there the Chiefs will be there
welcome everybody everybody with the
chief 6 o'clock we gotta be with the
Chiefs we're gonna smoke the Indian pipe
like they did in the outlaw Josie Wales
and for fluffy thing do you think I'm a
[__] that much I'm the great Stevie
Simonis I'm gonna leave Steve there for
a week is [__] you don't even know again
staying for a week he's gonna be the
drummer
since a good back
gotta breathe if you wanted to punish
I'm back my nose is about 72% I still
got some [__] up here he's the [__]
wash moves each it's a little breathing
I'll be [__] sniffing [__] in no
time I can sniff your ass all I'm
nervous no fun about six weeks right now
you back your ass to your phone I can
sniff that little muffler of death
where's Jenny Friedman at she have ever
smoked that dirty [__]
whose time is it now it's my brother Li
let's do this [__] you wanna do the last
Sunday
[__] you only go to telephones before my
run
yeah
what I'm doing assets I got [__] we was
really gonna hate Justin his whole
energy one Jesus what we all do it's
time for a bong [__] now we can't I
gotta start the morning on Monday fresh
but you were soul journey with us well I
love you [__] please willing to take a
bullet
he's like the Indian in the Outlaw Josey
Wales it's gonna be a big Indian week
around here
I got some angel dust coming some dude
makes legal angel dust will into a line
of peace in a week really and what's the
matter yes some frozen onion
how do you think it came here we go
[__]
besides I thought I was deep for a
minute insane
sometimes you go deep and kind of murky
waters that probably here we go with
some amateurs Oh
fan fan fan fan fan fan fan fan fan fan
fan fan fan fan fan fan fan fan of them
but if including you see nothing
no coffee no nut you working yourself up
if we're gonna be let's burn the rest of
it get the cardio kicking a football
level you want you wanna win split
they don't ladies and gentlemen [__]
soul he became a man right in front of
you [__] understand it doesn't
matter it's that type of neither church
so see what you want to do
do what you want to do you know I know
you got wanna go watch TV you want to
watch orange is the new purple let me
tell you something that's the warm up to
the [__] show when there's a warm-up
would he do you lately what do you do so
you're not enough Italian reefer
you better make a call and tell Blanco
to show up pump to bring over $35 sack
but it's time to get high you're right
Doug we went big tonight thousands
[__] milligrams live on periscope no
[__] stories this is the real deal
the Churchill what's happening now in a
[__] pot desk it's a state of mind
[__] in standing
just like that we get up early we watch
animals we we look out physis if we see
somebody who needs to get shot we call
Isis you know what's your purpose it
what the [__] was that that's like
[__] pull into the church ten minutes
we'll be back ready to rock this
[__]
my main man Steve Simone will talk about
charity very important time every job is
looking for a [__] charity then you
want to take 50% and the [__] black
kid with Y is on the moaning it's a
nickel you know pain
meanwhile you got a brand new motorcycle
you got a helmet you live in a life of
leisure go [__] yourself
we'll be back what is it youtube.com
slash Slee SAS Joey Diaz ultimate at
least side and that's a [__] face